he's as familiar as the face on the
dollar bill George Washington war hero
president the father of his country most
everyone knows this great man or thinks
they do but we're continuing to learn
that much of what we thought is fact is
actually fiction people made up things
about George during his lifetime after
his lifetime there's an industry in
falsifying George take one common
misconception that Washington's a man
born into privilege only reluctantly
accepting the greatness thrust upon him
in reality he starts out neither wealthy
nor modest
but as an ambitious youth faced with
tragedies he must struggle to overcome
Washington's correspondence hints that a
fire struck his childhood home on
Christmas Eve 1740 destroyed much of the
living quarters
he's only eight years old and life has
already dealt him a severe blow but his
path to success is soon blocked by a
greater obstacle the death of his father
George is devastated by his father's
death without that man to guide him
Washington was simply another child kind
of adrift in the world he depended on
his father for his financial stability
there's no longer any hope that he can
go to England to get the kind of
education that many people of his
standing in society would expect
his life as a farmer is often painted in
idyllic terms but in reality Washington
faces a fierce struggle to free himself
from rising debt through his 30s and 40s
he was in debt a great deal the tobacco
industry was manipulated controlled by
London merchants and he spent much of
his life trying to escape from being
indebted luckily he sees a way out of
this tobacco trap by switching to wheat
experimenting with fertilizers crop
rotation and other new farming
techniques Washington saves his family
from crushing debt George Washington's
face is plastered everywhere from the
dollar bill to used car ads yet these
depictions are highly romanticized his
true appearance has remained a mystery
until now modern technology is finally
exploring what he looked like in life
and even the details surrounding his
death Washington's most well-known
physical trait is his false teeth
despite his best efforts he loses all
but one tooth by the time he sworn in
his president his famous wooden teeth
are the stuff of legend but contrary to
popular belief they aren't made of wood
at all he has several dentures
constructed from ivory cow and even
human teeth
Washington bought some teeth from his
slaves
it is a grisly fact that he did this it
kind of gives you an image of slavery
that we don't think about after his
death the realities of Washington's life
become obscured by folklore legend
replaces fact and countless biographers
seek to romanticize his life and
personality but in canonizing Washington
many believe they do to service to the
man behind the myth